so John you have some experience as a
distributor is that right you were
that's right i had my own distribution
company we distributed the british film
the wicker man the original one that
edward woodward in christopher lee not
the remake with Nicolas Cage and also
Dennis hoppers out of the blue and a
Richard long crane movie called the
haunting of Julia with Mia Farrow and
Tom County and keir dullea did national
distribution indie distribution on those
movies that was before I started really
seriously working as a screenwriter and
producer and do you want to mention you
you rescued those movies because they
were on the show they were they were
kind of lost movies particularly the
wicker man we ended up restoring it to
the version that the director intended
and kind of kind of accidentally
invented a kind of classics division
distribution which didn't exist at the
time that's a whole whole nother topic
for a whole different interview but but
it gave me what I liked about it in
terms of what I do now is that I had to
create trailers I had to create posters
I had to do publicity on these films I
had to talk find get journalists
interested in them and set up interviews
and things so that was great background
for being an indie filmmaker didn't
really in a way doing studio level films
it was frustrating because kind of
sometimes I felt that I wanted to offer
advice where none was being asked and
but for an indie film where you have to
do everything at some point or other
it's it's I think a good background to
understand something about how the
business works and sales and
distribution as a producer's wrap to
which meant lots of times people would
bring me movies in various stages
finished
or sometimes not finished and I got a
little bit of a reputation as a film dr.
people could bring me movies that were
troubled and I can maybe make some
recommendations to improve them from
being on releasable to merely being
unbearable to watch no but that helped
you with directing too because you were
sort of helping directors get out of
holes and it helped train your ride you
know for the future yeah like I'll never
forget a great piece of advice I got
from some director along the way which
was more setups less takes I think one
of the big mistakes that you end up in
the post-production with is that you
wish you had some other angle of a shot
you wish you had something to cut away
with and instead you've got kind of the
perfect take of things that don't cut
together particularly well or don't help
you with the pace of the movie so I
really tried to remember to to do more
setups and not so many takes I mean you
have to get get it but you know
somewhere there has to be a compromise
where you're making an a modestly
budgeted indie movie and I tried to do
more takes I mean sorry to try to do
more setups listings and you mentioned
earlier a rescuing film so in keeping
with that rescuing the state of
independent film you know since 2008
things have changed everywhere can you
talk about where you see indie film
headed where's the audience well the
paradigm for movies generally is broken
and nowhere is it from an economic point
of view and nowhere is it more broken
than in the indie film space it's the
great news is that it's become easier
than ever to make a movie I mean it used
to be when I started out in the business
that if if you saw that a budget on a
movie was under a million dollars you
really
even bother to look at it you knew it
couldn't be something that could go into
theaters generally speaking there were
exceptions like Kentucky Fried movie and
a few other things may be naughty the
living dead but with rare exception you
you had to spend a million dollars at
the very least to make anything that was
releasable and now of course people are
making movies for under fifty thousand
dollars that look fun I mean they the
scripts may not be good the acting may
not be good those are usually the big
problems with indie movies the script
stinks and the acting stinks nothing has
changed you know it's also the problem
with studio movies is the script isn't
any good and the acting isn't any good
although with props to do movies at
least you have professional actors for
the most part it isn't the production
values where movies fall down it's its
story and its believability of acting so
in terms of making movies in the
distribution model you've now got a real
glut of movies out there and there are
gatekeepers never before have the
gatekeepers been so important you really
do need a producer's rep you really do
need to get into a first-rate festival
you really do need to get good reviews
in order to get anyone to really pay
attention to your movie and to have a
chance at distribution used to be you
made your indie movie you got into
Sundance and you SAT back and you waited
to see how many offers came in and if
you could get a bidding war going and
that paradigm has disappeared as all but
disappeared and I think that what's
happening in movies parallels would
happen in music few years ago which is
that movies are becoming ubiquitous
people can download the whole history of
movies it's available streaming on
Netflix it couldn't be more difficult
and more competitive to get an indie
movie into the marketplace and as a
result particularly in light of the
economic slump that
as a country and globally distributors
are very risk adverse when I would pick
up a movie like Dennis hoppers out of
the blue this was a movie a lunar
rejected because they thought it was too
tough that you know there was no way
audiences would would would would watch
this very intense movie with Linda man's
about about punk rock and I found you
know I found the right audience for it
and we spent an efficient amount of
money to do that but we took a risk
distributors today don't want to take
any risk and at least very few of them
do and it makes it very hard on indie
filmmakers and it makes the means that
the budgets have to go lower and lower I
mean that's really the first rule today
is how inexpensively can you make it and
make it for even less than that if you
possibly can I just want to say that I
you're not saying every movie has a bad
acting and bad scripts but right now I
just want to clarify that but for a four
and indeed all of us who all of us
making your knees and especially if
you're making inexpensive Indies it
behooves us to have a kick-ass script
and kick ass acting there's really no
excuse well my right or not i'm sorry i
just did since i guess i flubbed that
point at least with you wow that point
the point I was simply trying to make
was that he used to be that there it
costs a certain amount of money to get a
movie to a technically acceptable level
that amount of money has dropped so what
has always been the case when a movie
doesn't work it's usually because the
script doesn't work and because the
acting isn't good isn't
good enough even if the script does work
on some level those are the places where
movies fall apart so if you can hone
your script which is the cheapest thing
to do and if you can spend a lot of time
working with actors even if they're not
professional actors to get great
performances you can make your movie for
almost nothing today so it's really
easier than ever to make a good movie
and a great movie just the barriers are
what they've always been script and
performance because money and technology
have come down the barrier now is
distribution once you've made your movie
how do you get it seen is that clear
okay yeah no absolutely well why don't
you talk a little bit about what is
different from what happened in 2008 to
now you've got a clear understanding of
that in a concise way well I I don't
know that anyone quite understands that
the the what we all know what happened
globally to the real estate market and
and to the banking system and I think
that it expressed itself first in the
indie film business one of the things
that really happened was that the
studio's got into the indie film
business with classics divisions like
Warner Warner Warner independent and
paramount vantage joining fox
searchlight which had done it very
successfully they all had these
divisions and they all started kind of
raising the budgets of indie movies you
had movies like blindness love leaves
you know movie really an art house movie
though that paramount vantage made and I
think it was a 20 million dollar movie
and you know the the line between studio
movies in hindi movies was really
blurring and prices were going up and
the audience just wasn't there they were
may be overwhelmed by how many movies
they were being expected to embrace and
I think the marketing department
Studios perhaps didn't know how to cost
effectively market these smaller films
it was a big distraction from their
tempo movies their hundred million
dollar movies and I think they went back
to the business that they know better
but it's it's created a big dislocation
in the indie films mess so so if someone
wants so theatrical distribution is the
goal of every indie filmmaker so what is
your advice what is your advice I'm
interviewer you know but like one radio
free album moved that's we're committed
I don't think I don't think theatrical
distribution has to be the goal of every
indie filmmaker I think a lot of movies
it would be foolish to theatrical we
distribute them but with radio free
album oath we have a movie that because
of the philip k dick named Kyra Blade
Runner and Minority Report and Total
Recall and scanner darkly an adjustment
bureau we're able to really generate a
lot of marketing buzz and promotion
through theatrical and get reviews
through three optical that you couldn't
get otherwise depends what kind of movie
you have there's no there's no
generality I could very easily see
making a movie where I just totally
bypass theatrical but this movie was
kind of was kind of designed to be an
arthouse movie that you could do the
kind of cost effective distribution on
that i did with with wicker man and out
of the blue you know many years ago but
which there are a lot of companies that
do very well still like Magnolia and IFC
and oscilloscope